Hi friend, in AWS we use RDS as the
database. So in this video very short
quickly I will explain what is the
benefits of using RDS and comparison
with other databases. Okay. So let's
start what is Amazon RDS? How is it
different from the regular databases?
Now if you remember this pass category
then for applications you can host the
application in EC2 nor beanto or lambda
in a website. Similarly for data you can
use RDS for data RDS.
Okay here is one more very important
diagram where you can see our
applications are getting the data from
the RDS which is the database. Okay. Now
as a developer if you have used MySQL,
Oracle, SQL server etc. on your local
system
or in the onremise servers then Amazon
RDS is the same and the best RDBMS
database in AWS for you. You can use it
along with the Oracle or MySQL or any
database. Okay. So for database of your
uh if you want database for your
application select the RDS service in
AWS.
Here is the clear and short definition.
Amazon RDS is a fully managed
cloud-based relational database service
from AWS. It is offered as a platform as
a service meaning you just have to
provide the data the data struct uh
table structure whatever but you do not
have to install the Oracle or you do not
have to worry about the main
installations just you have to provide
the data to AWS and they will already
use RDS you have just to choose the RDS
service okay AWS will take care all for
managing the backups for you know
patching updates everything AWS will do
that's the diagram and that's the
definition and this definition diagram
will help you in the revision for your
interviews from this book
what is the difference between Amazon
RDS and Amazon RDS custom let's
now in AWS you can create two types of
RDS databases one is very normal normal
one and we call it simply RDS and
another one is the custom one which we
call RDS custom. Here is the first
difference between them. In standard RDS
you do not have full control over the OS
or DB. Okay, you do not you cannot
control the O operating system and
database. It's fully managed by the AWS.
You just have to create the tables.
Basically, your data stuff only you can
do. Whereas if you choose RDS custom,
you have full access to the OS DB
configurations
and most of the things meaning more
control you have in RDS custom. Okay.
Second difference is in for Amazon RDS
AWS manages the patching and the
backups.
You manage it in for Amazon RDS custom.
Okay. The backups, the patching,
everything. Okay.
Next, custom DB configurations are very
limited. You do not have to c you can't
customize it too much normal RDS
standard RDS but you have full
flexibility for modifying customer
configurations for RDS custom. Okay now
the most important question when to use
what? See here it is. If you are
creating a fresh and simple database
then go for Amazon RDS. But if you are
migrating some legacy database then and
there are the third party tools involved
then go for RDS custom because it
supports legacy apps. Third means you
have the full control. So you can you
know do the configurations as per your
old database
but in no standard RDS mostly things are
already there. So you have to uh you
can't customize too much. Okay. In short
go for RDS standard in most cases simple
and medium app development and in
complex migration legacy application
think about RDS custom. Okay that is the
answer to this question and everything
is written in this book. Your global
application needs a NoSQL database with
great response time. What would you
choose in AWS?
So, pause the video. You already know
the answer. Very simple. Done. Here is
it. Dynamob. Okay. It's a fully managed
multi-reion NoSQL database that provides
low latency red at any scale. Supports
global tables which makes it perfect for
apps with a worldwide user base. So it's
very popular also supported also Dynamob
and therefore it's good good option in
AWS. Okay, great job my friend. Now if
you understand RDS then there is one
more important database that is Dynamo
DVB very important for interviews that I
have explained in my complete AWS
interview boot camp.
Many of my students have already used my
courses to crack their interviews. Now,
if you don't want to miss a single
question for your next interview, then
check out the boot camp and book link in
the description below.